I think there are legitimate criticisms
of capitalism I think capitalism is a
word that was popularized by Carl I know
here we go no I mean it's a word
popularized by Karl Marx I think free
markets can be a wonderful thing and
often are a wonderful thing but they're
a wonderful thing as a means to an end
which is a good and flourishing society
and that when we make an idol out of
that we basically just worship Mammon
and and what we've done in practice as
we've done that is we've empowered woke
corporations who hate our guts who
actually pervert what we would consider
to be a kind of Ideal capitalism and
just use that against us and so I just
think you know as Chesterton pointed out
about Vice he said or about all the
evils of the modern world he said it's
not that we promote Vice so much as we
take a virtue a good thing like free
markets or being able to conduct
business and trade and we take it
completely out of proportion and out of
its proper place and so I think that can
be a a major problem